[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
columnist for the eye Ian Dunn and The
Spectators Deputy political editor Katie
balls both with us from now until just
before midnight welcome to both of you
so to the front pages then there we are
there's the Daily Mirror congratulating
Marcus rashford on scoring two goals in
the three nil World Cup victory over
Wales The Sun Also leads with rashford's
two goals which led the team to that
Victory against Wales this evening the
big win is also featured on the front of
the star the paper headlines The
Hangover suggesting England fans might
be feeling a little woozy tomorrow
morning
Delhi Telegraph leads with the deepening
NHS crisis as ambulance staff prepare to
hold the first strike in more than 30
years the eye carries census research
that shows for the first time in more
than 1500 years white Christians no
longer make up the majority of the UK's
population
the Ft has word of a possible loosening
of British Banking regulations which
proponents insist has been made feasible
because of brexit according to the times
Trials of a drug fought dementia
patients have revealed that it it
actively slows the condition that story
also makes the front page of the
Guardian their headline New Era of
progress in Alzheimer's research
the Metro reports on the death of a
Russian cryptocurrency tycoon in a
helicopter crash
and the Daily Mail warning of a
potential Christmas turkey shortage as
industry Chiefs fear the bird flu crisis
may have wiped out half of our free
range egg stock
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's go to Ian Dunn and Katie Bolton
there favorite subject Ian football
um The Daily Mirror for example
um bishrash Bosh a real celebration that
Marcus rashford scored two in that
performance although sympathy obviously
lies for her for all whale Wales fans
watching tonight
yes I started to feel a little glimmer
of excitement about the World Cup which
is about as much as I've managed over
the course of this tournament it's felt
um
well it's all completely wrong is I mean
even having it in Qatar is obviously
like a moral catastrophe on any number
of levels but just the basic fact that
it's happening in Winter that you don't
have that core sort of Summer feeling
I've been on the public if you try and
get a sense of is there a Great Big
World Cup feeling out there you kind of
don't feed it because you're not out in
the summer as much it's cold it's dark
less people want to go out to the
apartments it's been a bit of a
depressing tournament so far but
actually today I got moderately excited
which is my absolute High Benchmark so
far for this tournament well well done
to you lots of others definitely getting
excited some lovely photographs on the
newspapers including the guardian of
Gareth Southgate giving Marcus rashford
a real good hug you know clear clear
feelings of uh of Jubilation there a
sense of calmness I think they're trying
to keep the team calm too
um and yeah there's a real indoor Vibe
is there not kitty about fans
celebrating here in the UK on a a cold
November night
um some real themes of Celebration let's
listen
well let's see rather than listen
apologies no sound on that but uh that
was the first goal going in in East
London I think many fans as you can see
wearing raymax knowing that some of the
beer might be thrown but uh wrexham not
quite as happy let's take a look at
those pictures
oh some sadness there certainly Katie
but you know a lot of people have been
saying that at least it keeps politics
off the front pages for a while I'm
guessing you're one of those who agrees
with that at least
um yes I mean for professional reasons
not always
um but Downing Street I think are pretty
happy when football's on the front page
rather than the various problems the
government are facing and I also think
there's something else which is clearly
today with England versus Wales the
first time uh you know they've faced
each other in a World Cup match that is
you know that divides the United Kingdom
in terms of who you're supporting but
generally when you have a team doing
well I think if england keep progressing
it just does uh boost various things not
just spending but also I think it just
makes people feel more positive
generally and you saw that effect in the
euros and also just the fact that we're
now although I agree with Ian the fact
this is in Winter means it's not quite
the same
um you have if you think back to the
Euros that was during lots of covert
restrictions so it does feel like
getting back to normal in terms of some
of these sporting events seeing friends
as you as you watch them
yeah and um certainly for England if we
look at the other pictures as well the
Daily Star as well once again you know
celebrating Marcus rashford he's only 25
isn't he you know and already he's got
two euros and uh you know this is his
second world cup under his belt Phil
foden as well the other goal scorer only
22 but you feel for the likes of the of
the Welsh side like Gareth Bale in his
30s you know thank goodness um someone
like him Ian you know managed to get to
a world cup with his talents
uh yes I mean if you say so I don't
really have any idea who that person is
I do obviously know who Max rashford is
because of politics basic reason for it
because he's probably one of the most
accomplished political campaigners that
we've had in this country for the last
10 years certainly the most successful
and has managed to slay well any
politician that comes at him up to and
including the prime minister so on that
basis I at least know who that person is
and can comment on it my producer
roundly says that Gareth Bale is the
best person or best footballer these
islands have produced in a generation so
perhaps you should have a look at who he
is
brilliant for him that he that you know
the Wales has managed to get to a World
Cup for the first time since 1958 and uh
in a long way that continued shall we
move on to the eye UK Christians and
this is quite a headline isn't it or in
the minority for the first time since
the Dark Ages the latest census results
kt4 England and Wales
yes so the number has dropped um
ultimately when it comes to uh you give
you a Christian
um and it's down from nearly 60 a decade
ago
um and lots of coverage today about this
um people saying you know what's the say
of uh what what do we take from this
um but I think it also comes down to
things as as a society are we becoming
more secular as a society
um ultimately what is it that is driving
people away from saying they're
Christian and I think what the eye
highlights in its different page is the
fact that you know the church views on
women's rights abortion sexuality all
seem to be as factors that influence
this in terms of what you what you tip
when you're when you're surveyed for
this
um and I think there is something which
is I think some people would probably if
they had to pick which religious values
they had they might talk about having
Christian values but they would stop
short saying that they were Christian if
that makes sense yes I think if you
asked a slightly different question you
know if there was one religion to which
you felt you know most culturally close
to or had the values of they might it
might be Christian but you know the eye
suggesting Ian um that um other changes
the church's views on women's rights
abortion and sexuality have influenced
the decline which I'm not sure I fully
understand but you know does it say much
about about England and Wales the these
figures
yeah I haven't seen any information that
would necessarily suggest that it's
connected to those social issues we've
been seeing this demographic change for
a long time and it's much more severe
than it's coming across in the census
the census has a very leading question
in it which is what is your religion now
you'll notice if you say that right it
sort of presumes that you have a
religion that's basically what a poster
would call a leading question when you
don't ask it in that way for instance
the British social attitude survey says
is there a religion that you belong to
which is a much stronger form of
Association and doesn't assume that
you're in a religion now what's been
coming up with it came up with numbers
around this 11 in the mid 40s 10 years
ago so we would presume that actually
the level of Christian faith in this
country is even lower than we're seeing
in the Census Data it's not the
synthesis Fault by the way I mean the
reason they do this is because they're
not really interested in faith they're
insured in self-identification and
that's not about faith that's about
ethnicity it's about your culture when
you ask people why are you Christian one
of the things that they mostly answer is
saying well my parents are Christians
things like that it's not really about
do they believe in Christ do they
believe he was the son of God truth is
you look at this country this is a
profoundly irreligious secular country
it's one of the most secular countries
on Earth has a huge range of different
beliefs and effective immigration and
has a lot of people a massive amounts of
people that have no faith at all it's
about time that we started looking at
our politics specifically the role that
monarchy specifically the Bishops in the
Lords and specifically the bizarre
cultural traits we have like thought for
the day uh in the on the radio in the
morning and start thinking why on Earth
do we have these things given the way
that the population thinks okay that's
it interesting certainly but um moving
on to the ft and
um you know this is this is brexit and
the financial crisis combined in this
story is it not post the financial
crisis parts of banking
um were had to be separated uh the
retail and investment arms had to be
ring fenced the idea from the government
in is that this should be relaxed in
some way Katie tell us more
yes so ultimately this is the Ft
reporting comments by Andrew Griffith a
Minister city Minister
um to an ft conference
um about how we just discussed the
retail investment split is seen as
inefficient and this is this real change
would not actually benefit the largest
lenders it would benefit small lenders
in terms of freeing up what they can do
but I think crucially you can see in how
it's being pitched by the government
they're trying to say this is you know
Big Bang 2.0 but also trying to pitch as
a brexit freedom and I think it goes to
um a desire by the government after
weeks months of ultimately lots of
people say you know the government has
nothing to show of brexit which is
positive I think there's been a desire
for ministers to try and Pitch various
things and you can start to see saying
oh we are using freedoms though of
course we need to see uh really how this
actually rolls out and and if it is such
a thing
in quick one on that or do you want to
move on to uh the mortgage issue post
the Liz trust mini budget
absolutely nothing to do
extremely predictably because anytime a
minister stands up and says this is a
brexit benefit you can bet every dollar
that you have on you that it will have
absolutely nothing to do with brexit we
introduce this as a government ourselves
in the wake of the financial crash and
the reason we did it is because there
are a bunch of retail Banks buying up
Securities there are a bunch of
investment Banks selling mortgages that
they were packaging up into
collateralized debt obligations and it
almost tanked our economy we've now
decided to go the other way create a
massive risk premium on the basis of it
and package it up with a bunch of PR
that has absolutely no basis in fact
whatsoever okay and the mortgage crisis
inside the times
foreign
in front of the Lord's economics
committee today
um so we it's put by some as the sort of
idiot premium that because there's more
trust in what is going on in Government
after the departure of Liz truss we
might see a slight easing down of
mortgages but it's probably going to
come too late for about half of the
people um not a victory mortgages who
are going to be facing some kind of
change in the cost over the next year so
even as an alleviate it won't
necessarily come down starkly or quickly
enough to be saving the people who are
about to be hit by that Financial impact
okay lots more stories after break too
stay there both of you Katie and Ian for
the moment thank you very much indeed
lots more to come including Trials of a
new dementia drug yielding promising
results we will examine that next
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me once again Ian Dunt and
Katie balls welcome back to both of you
so Katie let's go to the Delhi Telegraph
shall we news of another Union and more
strike action uh Unison suggesting that
some 80 000 of its members supported
taking industrial action and they're
talking about paramedics and other
ambulance workers and other staff in the
NHS as well so the the difficulties of
strike action and specifically the NHS
continues
yes and ultimately this is just adding
to this winter discontent Mass strikes
we're expecting and if this does go
ahead and there's another ballot
tomorrow
um ambulance staff this will be the
first time in 30 years eminent staff
have striked you add to this the fact
that um if you think about the current
ambulance delays the wait times
um already with you know star operating
on a full basis there are huge problems
um so it's an only further add to the
strain there's serious concerns in
government about whether the NHS can
actually you know stay up over the
winter with all the pressures it's
facing and you also have the nurses uh
plan to strike and the government for
now is holding the line that it is not
going to give in in terms of these paid
demands to the level that they are
asking for saying simply the money is
not there and but I think in the face of
decisions to you know raise pensions
keep the triple lock benefits and line
of inflation and lots of these workers
public sector workers are you know
thinking that they're actually
um you know a possibility that if they
press on they will get this particularly
the cost of living crisis so it's really
hard to see the resolution and as ever
when the government is in trouble um in
the telegraph story you get to the point
where they start talking about drafting
the Army in and I think that could only
go so far
um so there's some talk about army army
members managing to fill in but it's not
going to fix it particularly when um
it's the government's go-to and there's
many many problems coming up in the next
few months yeah I think paragraph 10 is
the Army in this Telegraph article but
they do talk about altogether about 200
000 health workers are now understood to
be backing strikes a hundred thousand
nurses already set to strike on December
the 15th and 20th
um it's about pay the difficulties for
the NHS also about the fact that mainly
older patients can't be discharged
because there's no one to care for them
in the social care sector you know more
staffing issues there so what does the
government do about all of this then Ian
oh
you know the funny thing is if you look
at elements like actually being able to
discharge people from Beds which has an
effect not just you know on the beds
themselves but also on things like a e
as severe knock-on effects of that this
is the kind of thing that when there was
a functioning Downing Street and you had
sort of delivery unit strategy unit
policy unit people thinking through how
different parts of the system
for instance a lack of capacity in
Social care would impact on things like
a e waiting times you could work it down
but none of that was quick all of that
took years you know right now you look
at the situation that is not something
that's going to clear up over this
winter and it's certainly not something
that's going to clear up even by the
time that we get to the next election if
I was in government I'd be looking you
might think that people don't like
strikes or they're really going to see
is the fact that they are not safe
themselves on the basis of an economy
and a public sector that has just simply
stopped working under this government's
authorship Katie let's go to two
newspapers that are leading on news of a
breakthrough in Alzheimer's research and
the guardian talks about the dawn of a
new era and the times is actually
talking about a cure quite
extraordinarily a cure for Alzheimer's I
mean if so you know how extraordinary
and how amazing
yes completely and of course it's one of
those things where you don't get ahead
of yourself and this is all based on a
clinical trial results and but it's very
obvious from both the reports and and
the data in it that it points to a
potential breakthrough and we know in
Alzheimer's research that it's been a
you know a long journey to try and find
ways to treat
um an illness which is you know
um very painful not particular person it
affects but for close family as they see
their loved ones and you know change
before them and and the dangers that
come with that in terms of um
self-sufficiency and actually up to this
point
um there's been a problem where there
hasn't really been any uh you know
significant treatment options and this
is showing uh you're looking at it what
it did is if you had an early stage as
this treatment and then it seemed to
slow things down and while at the moment
it was uh you know it does it doesn't
fix everything and it is a small
Improvement I think the very fact
they're seeing that there is attention
treatment which is having an effect is a
game changer and does open uh the way to
a potential cure in the medium long term
if this does continue to be the case
then further research can be done
yes they talk about um 27 uh slowing
memory decline over 18 months but
nonetheless a major Improvement quick 30
seconds on turkeys in the Daily Mail Ian
Christmas turkey shortage Fair bird flu
crisis wiping out you know up to half of
our free-range stock the paper says
yes this is concerning isn't it I mean
it's not as bad as if they said the pigs
in blankets we're going to go through
some kind of shortage because that's
basically the highlight of any sane
person's Christmas the turkey things the
problem and it certainly seems that the
prices of turkeys are going up by virtue
of of what is happening there so yeah
this is another part of our winter of
discontent it's the fact you're not even
going to get a turkey at Christmas yeah
but at least you didn't say brussels
sprouts I thought you were at one point
gonna say that was the highlight better
not for most of us uh both of you see
you later thank you very much indeed uh
the very latest in the 11 of course on
that game